we will not tolerate such a brazen
attempt to murder innocent civilians on
our soil British Prime Minister Theresa
May says it is highly likely Russia is
responsible for poisoning a former spy
with military-grade nerve agent in
southwestern England her government has
summoned Russia's ambassador to the
United Kingdom
Alexander Yakov an Co to explain by
tomorrow whether his government either
executed the attack or lost control of
its nerve agent should the be no
credible response we will conclude that
this action amounts to an unlawful use
of force by the Russian State against
the United Kingdom ney says it cannot be
business as usual with Russia and
Britain would consider much more
extensive measures than diplomatic
expulsion czar limited sanctions last
week Sergei scrapped all and his
daughter were found on a park bench
poisoned there in the hospital in
critical stable condition the Russian
government convicted scrap all of spying
for the British and in 2006 sent him to
prison in 2010 he arrived in the UK as
part of a spy swap this afternoon a
British reporter asked President
Vladimir Putin whether he was behind
scrap Paul's poisoning that I give you
get to the bottom of things there first
then we'll discuss this the Russian
Foreign Ministry calls May speech a
circus show in the British Parliament
and the Kremlin spokesperson says Russia
had nothing to do with the attack this
Russian citizen worked for one of the
British intelligence agencies the
incident took place on British territory
and therefore it has nothing to do with
Russia but alone the Russian leadership
the State Department official says the
United States will support its greatest
ally the UK as for a u.s. retaliation
against Russia for this the official
says the British government has not
asked the United States to join its
response